the historic west side of Las Vegas
continues to grow that's right well
today adding a medical center for senior
citizens archwell Health promising a
number of services for residents
sometimes it was it was hard sometimes
you don't get the care that you want
Luther Clarke has been living in Las
Vegas this historic West Side for
decades and has seen firsthand the
growth but today that included more
access to health care it's very
important and and with me coming here
yesterday
taking a test I took they found out that
I really need some a lot of work done
and stuff that I had I didn't know I had
problems with you know with this here
Clark is talking about the new Medical
Center archwell Health debuted on Owens
and H Street this is the newest of five
facilities across the valley with easy
accessibility for Primary Care for
Seniors without being running across
town way over here way over there for
doctors and stuff you know or to the
labs and all that stuff you know so this
is really convenient everything's here
we try to make our centers One-Stop
shops so blood work initial testing
um we you know we have all that right
here if we need to get a specialist
involved we can do that among the list
of services social work and
nutritionists to guide each patient and
what some say is a complicated Health
Care System right now is what Medicare
calls annual enrollment period and
that's when Medicare recipients can
change their plans and choose their new
medical groups and such so they they
would need to call us make sure that we
take their insurance as a historic West
Side continues to undergo a
revitalization residents like Clark are
supporting the much needed change
beginning with his well-being
well we are told that each doctor at
these five centers will have fewer
patients to ensure each person has an
average of 40 minutes with the doctor